move the conversation I want to get
YouTube's uh opinion so like like what
countries are you from and in your
community what is the perception of like
uh single parents like it's not well
what is your background your country
so um
can you repeat the question no okay what
country okay basically what country are
you from or what do they think of single
moms okay so I'm coming from Hungary
yeah and um I do believe there is a lot
of uh problem with women being single on
a very early stages because they get
Childs very soon very young and I
actually can say that from my high
school
almost every single of my classmates has
a kid and almost most of them doesn't
have a father wow or like not in the
picture anyway so I would I don't think
most people would have even known that
like you know what I'm saying like
that's crazy like
um so do you think it's like the you
know the causes that we were talking
about earlier do you think that's what's
causing I think many many reasons can
apply on that like many many things that
we have covered during this
conversations but I think the main issue
is is that in my country you get a lot
of money if you have a kid okay and I
think the mentality is the problem with
some of the people and of course there
are a lot of exceptions but a lot of
people is that the with the mentality of
let's have a kid so we can have more
money oh wow okay I didn't I didn't know
that that's crazy so that's that's one
of the things but that's the trick that
the government do in my country so they
basically say that to you yes you can
get all of these money but eventually
you have to pay that back and with so
large amounts of interest that you're
gonna pay it back in your life
so um that's what that that's actually
fair I like that yeah that's kind of
fair it's really smart and because
you're gonna he's gonna bite you in the
Box even in the end like do you get what
I'm saying that makes sense yeah okay
exactly so I think that's that's one of
the main main issues so can I ask it's
so hungry right hungry so so there's no
Stigma to being a single parent there's
no like you know like culturally it's
like oh you're a single parent that's
like you it's not looked down upon
I wouldn't say but really honestly with
you I cannot really express my opinion
to like properly in a way I want to
answer your question because I came to
the UK when I was 18 years old okay so
what is it that you do in your early
ages like since age of 16 till 18 I've
probably been partying every weekend
going to school and just like doing my
so you don't really know yeah yeah
obviously had my own reasons to like be
out so I'm the kind of person who
actually knows how to grow up how to be
a grown-up on the street so
um I've been in multiple times in
situations where I had to literally beg
for money just to buy lunch so I can 100
relate on many many conversations that
that has been said but I cannot 100
relate like answer to you like how is
the current situation so what I can tell
is what I see on the social media by
following my friends and people who I
used to know in my country almost every
single one of them I would say say maybe
I would say less than less than five
person who has another kid wow how much
money would would a woman get for a
child roughly in UK money I mean I
cannot really say um because I haven't
really looked into it I never really
planned to get that some just by having
a kid but um obviously compared to the
UK Hungarian foreignty is extremely [ __ ]
sorry to say it but let's just put it
that way the minimal wage if I'm not
wrong is roughly around four to five
hundred pounds a month I think I maybe
I'm saying stupid I don't know I have to
look into it again because like I said I
basically grew up in the UK so I don't
really know but it's really really low
okay really really low and the prices
are very similar to UK so oh okay that
is a reason why people choose to have
kids just to get the money sorry I'm
awesome next young lady so what country
are you from and what what is the
general consensus about like you know
single mothers like is it frowned upon
or what and I have kept quiet for the
past you know 30 minutes just because it
wasn't really in my place to comment on
you so I brought you in that's why I'm
smart with it but um we're the opposite
of what you just said so I'm full Hong
Kong I'm full Chinese and in our culture
it's extremely extremely rare almost
non-existent that someone would have a
child outside of being married to them
um a large part of that maybe is that
like culturally there is also a lot of
Shame and stigma around having a child
outside of marriage so if you're a woman
and you get pregnant outside of being
married your family basically is
disowning you like all the shame is on
you you're on your own like you're
screwed basically so I don't know if the
two things are correlated but also in
Hong Kong like we're a lot more
conservative about the way relationships
work like there's no hookup culture
really or it's a lot less than here and
it goes back to what we were saying
before like why are there more and more
or like you know why is it so normalized
and it's because the benefits are
starting to outweigh the costs almost
like in Western culture the benefits of
getting pregnant outside of being in a
relationship or outside of marriage is
you get free money and almost now it's
respected instead of being frowned upon
so as a woman like it because it's so
normalized it's not so frowned upon it's
there's less barrier like this less
entry to doing it if that makes sense
yeah whereas the cost of it in the past
yeah there was a lot more stigma there
was a lot more shame nowadays it's not
really the case it's celebrated
yeah yeah that's what I think I said
that a bit earlier like the issue of
there's no shame in this like over here
let's it's just not
you know you became a single mom well
okay join the club kind of thing you
know what I mean so yeah and I
definitely
um
I'm gonna shout out the last Super chats
and I think I'll wrap it up with that
I'm gonna I'm gonna do that right now
yeah we get the final words after Super
Chat I think if I can I can't even
scroll up blessing can you bring it up
on the screen because I can't even get
them up on my phone
all right we got Alice star for the
Super Chat it all stems from a
combination of emotion and Authority
people need to give up give up one or
the other authority and emotion
yeah no you're right I hear you he is a
balancing act I think well let's move to
the next one
NSX big up to you man constantly
supporting he says Rich bro one breath
you will argue a straight woman a trait
woman find attractive is money or clout
women describes not wanting a baby
unless she likes him riches no you're
wrong she'll do it for money or clout
I said a woman would go for a guy for
money or clout bro what are you talking
about I think I'm sure I said that you
know you did you did you did no no I
think that's what you're saying now you
said rich is riches no you're wrong
nothing he's quoting you I think oh well
done this yeah you're a smart guy bro
you're smiling me I was getting it all
wrong
it's because I'm in attack mode anyway
but I've got my gcses I remember the the
the speech bubble yeah I'm just trying
to I'm trying to read it too quick I
pick up Michael for the super sticker I
think it was a super sticker we got Mark
is that it yeah
all right big out to everyone I support
and make sure you hit the like button
you're watching this on the playback
make sure you hit the like button it's
very very important yeah now I'm going
to give everybody a chance to say their
last word and yeah let's close it out so
what do you want to say what's your last
words
really honestly with you it was a great
pleasure to be here I really have
nothing more to add on like um I really
did enjoy to talk with you all and
hopefully sharing some useful opinions
um about my past and
um if not then I'm sorry yeah so um yeah
thank you so much again for being here
and I really have nothing else to to add
on so yeah
uh okay just a quick take home message
for the woman is when you're choosing a
guy make sure you pick a partner not
just based on the materialistic things
that he has but also how what he does to
pursue you and how he acts towards you
awesome I mean I guess kind of right I
hate that but we're talking about a kid
yeah just make sure like they've got all
those traits in the sense of being ready
for a child number one spend time with
that person get to know them first don't
be having don't be getting pregnant in
the first month you're not gonna know no
one in that time so yeah listen love
life enjoy
all right
let's go bro
um listen we're all human
girls boys if you want to be sexually
active and you know what I mean do your
thing do your thing but just other
element of responsibility and try not to
be selfish and bring kids into the world
where
not necessarily not wanted but you know
I mean if you can't if you can't afford
to have a clove feed or look after that
kid with optimal you know what I mean
just try and be a bit more
let's be a bit more cautious still do
your thing enjoy life
um my takeaway message would be people
just work in partnership with your
partners and don't look at social media
for validation stick to your path and
explore your options look at Family
Dynamics don't just jump in the deep end
and you know
do a lot of self-reflection it's
important to know yourself before you
get into a relationship
awesome
um I'd like to say bring back baby mama
shaming man move like the Chinese uh
shame is shaming is part of the reason
why you'd like to think people would do
the right thing but shaming is part of
the reason why some men don't wouldn't
want to go through for younger people
just because of the stigma attached or
why a man who's hungry wouldn't Rob an
old lady so if you know it is bring it
back and then hopefully it'll be less
baby mums around there
I may make the distinction a baby mom
and a woman who's Divorced with a child
of very two different things
auntie
I'm gonna agree
when I was growing up
when I had my son
I keep on going to some people's asses
they Banned Me
because like you said I was surrounded
by my culture it was like oh my God look
at her she has a baby and then because I
was the oldest daughter it was like
she's encouraging her sisters to have
children and one thing you're saying
about where we come from
my mom comes from Barbados
and back in the day it was shameful now
it's like oh wild my dad comes from
Montserrat and I found that in Monster
app
you have a child you look after it
there's no other help out there it's not
like oh you have a child the
government's going to support you
and they weren't so much but then when
the volcano happened and they come over
here
you find that the women were having
babies then get rid of the men because
it's a slightly that England gave them
money so where before it's like a father
had to support his child a monsterat
because there's no money coming from
nowhere else there's no the government's
not giving you any money you have the
child use not support it and then I
realized that when they came over here
it was like you know what we're getting
money for having a job we don't need you
and then they go off and and have loads
and loads of children but in my day I
was shamed I was shamed for having a
child
you know even like for walking down
there it's like oh yeah you see someone
says and I mean look at her she's not
married she got some and that's what I'm
saying that after that early late 80s
early 90s that's when it all changed so
I just think to myself men keep it
covered government
don't pay for children why are you gonna
pay me to have a child why why do you
need child benefit anyway don't work
other countries do it without child
benefit why do I why are they paying
people that's why everybody wants to
come here because England pays you to
breed whether or not you got whether or
not you've got a partner they pay you to
breed I'm hungry
because I think that if they made you
pay it back that she said with interest
exactly that's what she said I wasn't I
was listening because I like that with
interest
because I never got nothing from the
government I was working I was working
because I wasn't raised
to depend on anyone for money my mom was
a single parent she never got no free
preschool dinner is nothing
I was the same a lot of being shamed is
protect people from from their bad
behaviors so are you Nance are you slag
are you little fatty that's what I want
don't do these mad behaviors
that's it yeah I hear it you can't shame
me twice
so basically basically all in all bring
back the shaming yeah yeah bring back
the shame bring up the Chinese just have
some pride in yourself man have some
pride in yourself keep it covered man
keep it coming and another thing hey
yeah guys yeah even though we've been
talking about poor choices women make
poor choices men we make poor choices as
well I know I've done it many times all
right keep it covered stay strapped in
it anyway with that being said as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible